what sort of things are you looking for
that you're not finding um I think it's
hard to find guys that have Direction
have purpose have goals and values that
are aligned with what my goals and
values
are um let me
just so you want a driven man that is
aligned with your goals and values so
what are your goals and values um I
would say the biggest thing is my goals
are to have a family I want to get
married and I'm looking for someone who
primarily hopefully is Christian and
holds those values as well because I
think that that's very fundamental to
having the sort of family that I'm
looking
for um and that's hard those things are
hard to find with what we're sifting
through right now so
you're um that's interesting I mean
my last boyfriend was 24 so that's
probably what are you doing with a 24y
old if you're
35 and you want to have a family like
that's not really align with that goal
is it well at the time I thought it was
uh you honestly thought a 24y old wanted
to have children with a 35y old that's
what he said you know and I kind of I
believed him and just like when guys say
that I can just be friends with you you
also believe that sure yeah but I mean
he treated me really well like I
wouldn't say it was a bad relationship
it was pretty positive for the most part
but obviously at the end of the day it's
like he was not ready for those things
so I mean yeah so um I'm definitely
looking my age and older is really what
I'm what do you bring to the table at 35
that a guy you know should contemplate
because um you know you're on this
mission to have a family and kids I love
that question yeah I think a few things
like I'm definitely really family
oriented I have a great family um my
values are very traditional like and
from what I'm finding too like
especially like dating and like meeting
different
guys they they don't really meet a lot
of girls like that either so it's kind
of refreshing for them and it's
refreshing for me when I meet someone
that has some of those same things that
are in alignment um but I mean those are
the main ones like I make good money
like I have a good career like there's a
lot of things that I think you're
essentially describing a man
though J most most guys are not
generally concerned with how much money
or the type of career or the number of
degrees that they're their woman has
it's just not something that they're
generally screening for or looking for
it's not an attraction trigger that men
have in women it's an attraction trigger
that women look for and Screen foreign
men but often what what a lot of women's
a pitfall fall a common Pitfall that a
lot of women have is that they take the
traits that they look for in men and
they think that they need to embody
those same traits and as we establish at
the beginning of the show men and women
are different and they look at each
other differently and there's different
standards that apply it'd be the same
thing if it was like well I want a
really feminine woman who gets her hair
done all the time and keeps her nails
long and wears makeup and you know wears
tight little skirts that's what I need
to wear so I can attract a
woman Ian on no Planet would that ever
work I mean there there's no woman
that's going to be attracted to me for
looking like a and acting like a woman I
think that that's totally fair that's
part of the reason why that wouldn't be
the first thing I listed however I would
say that you know I guess most men that
I interact with they seem appreciative
of the fact that I seem to have my [__]
together I guess would you like to be a
stay-at-home mom or like a professional
mom like one that goes to work I my
dream would be to be a stay home mom so
your career your income none of that
really matters and if you're going to be
a stay-at-home mom because that's all
going to get abandoned to raise the
babies right so what you need is a
successful guy yeah so successful guys
are usually not 24 they're usually your
age or older because it takes a guy like
a little while to work into that sort of
you know success in his life I would say
that's totally fair um the 24 year-old
that I'm talking about
definitely was one of those ones that
was successful which is great but I
don't even think it's just about that I
think a lot of it is just obviously
maturity and kind of understanding who
you are what do you think he needs to
make to sort of take care of you and a
family in Detroit like on an annual
basis I mean that's a great question but
at the end of the day I mean I think
it's all about your priorities I think
it's all about what your priorities are
I think there's a lot of people that no
that's kind of a Loosey question I mean
I'm going to hold you accountable to
this one so so I mean if you want to be
a at home mom you want to raise a babies
that that would be your dream and you
live in Detroit I mean you must have
thought about what he must earn to
facilitate that dream right I think I've
seen people do this sort of thing in
different ranges I mean I think
realistically you'd want someone that's
making six figures I think that that
would make it probably a more
comfortable lifestyle for what I'm
looking at um well I mean six figures is
100,000 and 999,000 like those are two
very different numbers like what what
would you have to see yeah if you're if
you're making $100,000 like you could
probably have a modestly comfortable
life in this area there's got to be
loads of guys in Detroit that make 100
Grand that are you know qualified to
marry you and put babies in you though
maybe I don't know I'm having some
really weird encounters okay so talk
about the weird encounters then so
what's
happening um well there was a recent one
so I was trading with this guy for a
while he seemed really funny he seemed
really cool so he asked me out on a date
um we met up for a drink and then we
walked down the street we went and got
some oysters and some more drinks and we
literally talked for hours um he was
like super funny really
intelligent and we just had a really
good time um he was in law enforcement
like just was like a dude like a normal
dude which is like not an easy thing to
find I feel like and um
after the date he texted me and he just
like told me what a great time he had
and like how attractive he thought I was
and I was like awesome you know like
this is great he texted me the next day
we talked and
then completely just like went into the
ether like I didn't hear from him and
normally I would just let it go you know
I something shifted he whatever decided
he didn't like me for whatever reason
but this really kind of bothered me and
it was like on my mind I was like no
like I'm not saying every guy that I
meet like Falls desperately in love with
me but also like I have a pretty good
barometer like when someone likes me and
when they don't and this guy was into me
right so I get drunk one night it's like
11:15 it was a Friday and I decided to
text him and all I said was hey I'm a
little mad at you
FYI he responds immediately
and he
says hey I totally get that I'm so sorry
I just have a lot going on right now and
I figured it was best for me to be on my
own for a little bit which obviously
sounds like a total [__] excuse so I
just replied and I said okay I said
Thank you for telling me and I was just
going to leave it at
that but then he continues and he was
like no he's like I'm not bullshitting
you he was like I'm being totally
serious and he proceeds to tell me like
I was just at this family party on
Saturday my dad showed up dressed fully
as a woman with all the surgeries that
you can't come back from and that's how
he decided to announce to all of us that
he was
trans and you know his family's very
conservative like whether you're
conservative or not I mean this is going
to throw everyone for a loop if this
wasn't anything they were expecting and
he was like that's just the tip of the
iceberg and he started to like get into
more stuff and I was just like thinking
to myself I'm
like what like this is like this is the
kind of crazy stuff it's like you can't
even make this up so that was a recent
one I mean if I heard that story from a
chick I'd just be like [__] move on
that's what I I'm like [__] I did
move on um I I definitely did didn't get
the sense that he was being dishonest
like I really didn't that was actually
the entirely plausible in today's world
that that could have happened I mean 30
years ago I tell you to pound sand but
it's entirely possible today that that
could have happened but that's just
that's just part of the numbers game so
that's just one guy I mean surely you've
dated more than one guy I mean there
must have been some other options out
there yeah there was another guy before
him um he was actually a single dad and
so that's kind of why I found that
conversation so interesting earlier but
you know in his situation lots of baby
mama drama no good no good relationship
there so that made things really tough
he had the kid 50% of the time it was
really difficult so it's like it's a lot
of things that I think both men and
women are waiting through right now that
are just things that like our parents
did not have to deal with I don't think
anyone could have prepared us for what
the dating scen is right now in like you
know Jillian you're 35 like when did you
decide that you wanted to have a family
and
children when did I decide probably when
I was
28 like for sure I always knew I wanted
to have like a family and stuff like
that but like for sure when I was 28
like I made a lot of changes in my life
to make you're coming up on seven years
though so why is it so why is it not
happening um I would say like I had
long-term relationships that just didn't
work out the way that I wanted them to
what do you think of the notion that a
woman as she gets older um and she's
sort of gone through life and
experienced more men and has more bag
like do you think that you're
as like an equal Prospect to a guy as
somebody Kenzie's age you know for
example like a woman that's younger I
think depends on I think it depends on
the person and what you care about you
know what I mean I think that for me
personally when I was 23 I was a totally
different person than I am today and I
actually think that the knowledge and
wisdom and the experience and just
everything I've been through I actually
think I'm better
aligned
for the partner who would be a better
fit for me um I don't even think I knew
who I was when I was 23 I think I was
stupid and I'm not saying that about KY
do you think you raised your standards
since you're
23 I think my standards are different
you know I think when I was 23 I wanted
like a super hot ripped dude I think now
that's not like on the top of my
priority list I think there's other
things that I care about a lot more so
you'll make a few concessions you can be
a little bit of a dad bot it's not as
important it's more you's got the
ability to provide for a a family right
and wants and wants those things yeah
what are some of these pieces of wisdom
and experience that you think makes you
more valuable now than maybe you were 12
years ago I think I'm
definitely I just have more I was raised
in a very traditional household and I
think I fell into the Trap that a lot of
girls do especially when you're young
like I went to college and had all these
like really toxic ideas pumped into my
head and like I also worked in radio for
10 years so that was pretty crazy I was
like moving around for these jobs and
that's not really conducive to having
you know a normal life or a
family um I thought it was cool to be
like interviewing celebrities and doing
all this stuff and at the time sure it
was great but you know those aren't the
things that really matter to me at the
end of the day the pay what I was
sacrificing wasn't worth it and I think
like my priorities are just different
like I think I've value things that are
of more substance I think what I'm
looking for is of more substance hold on
really quick rich I want to get to
Kenzie in a second after this but I'm so
what I'm hearing is this was sort of the
result
of basically like toxic feminism telling
you to go be the boss babe go make the
money you can wait push it off do all
these things make all this money get all
these degrees and then you'll have you
know all these men line up about your
door when a little bit I mean I I would
say I was more moderate um I was never
like a super feminist or anything like
that but I guess I just thought it would
naturally happen you know like I thought
oh yeah like I'm you know I'm just
naturally gonna meet that guy we're
naturally just going to get married and
it's not something I really have to
prioritize or focus on and I think that
that's something that you know I
definitely wish I would have had a
better perspective on when I was younger
for sure I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that here
that clips from if you're new to the
channel make sure you hit subscribe over
here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out